así en días de llegar al palacio de plan
alto el mandatario ha hecho de su
bandera recuperar los programas de ayuda
sociales sin embargo su aprobación ronda
apenas el 40% A qué se debe este
fenómeno
en primer lugar porque fue una elección
muy muy apretada de Luis Ignacio tiene
apenas dos por ciento de encima de su
competidor Entonces es natural país
dividido hay un grupo muy grande de
lectores de derecho de derecha y que
rechacen la administración de Luis
Ignacio rural para después que los
programas la red tomada en los programas
sociales se deban tener un efecto a más
a medio plazo entonces pensó que ese es
dudas razones luego a que lo apoyo al
presidente a este momento no esté a cima
de los cuarenta por ciento Bueno usted
lo estaba mencionando y veíamos en el
discurso del presidente Lula que
arremetió contra Jair bolsonaro en medio
de un ambiente tan polarizado y con el
antecedente del Ataque a los poderes del
6 de enero Cómo analiza usted este
mensaje del mandatario
por favor se puede repetir la pregunta
porque no no puede eludir le pregunto
que en medio de la polarización que vive
Brasil este en este mensaje en este
discurso Lula cargó contra bolsonaro y
pues vemos esto con el antecedente del
ataque del 6 de enero Cómo analiza usted
este discurso del mandatario
está haciendo una dificultad de hacer un
gobierno más amplio internos de agrupar
Alianza
entonces este discurso sí refuerza a
aquellos que son de la izquierda y más
los grupos identitarios con cual Lula
tiene mucha facilidad de hablar pero no
amplía para los grupos de Centro que
muchos de él hubieron votado para para
sonar en la primera elección y después
cambiaron para Lula Entonces pienso que
sí lo el presidente hay que hacer un
esfuerzo más grande para incorporar a
los los seguimientos de centro a su
plataforma de gobierno Bueno y con el
actual panorama que tiene Brasil Cuáles
se pueden considerar los principales
retos que tiene el mandatario para el
resto de su administración
pero pienso que hay dos objetivos más
claros Primero este
envolver a la economía brasileña en un
ciclo virtuoso que poesa dar cuentas
sociales entonces la economía es sin
duda de ñuma lo los desafío más
importante de este momento hay también
que hacerse un proceso de
desonalización
de las áreas de seguridad pública que
quedaron muy capturadas por los
gobiernos de extrema derecha Entonces
pienso que hay un programa económico por
en Plaza con las repercusiones sociales
de esto que también un programa de
defensa del Estado de derecho y la
democracia